[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Matt hi Mavis and I'm a
cellist I'm here for a residency at
Miller theatre and playing the six cello
suites of Johann Sebastian Bach and I've
also commissioned six composers each one
to write an overture for a different one
of the Suites for the Bach Suites and so
it's it's a big cycle we're doing it in
two ways we're doing it three cello
suites and three overtures in the
concert hall at Noda Theatre on two
separate nights Thursday and Saturday
and we're also doing it as a moveable
feast in the way or we're moving things
around and I'm showing up in places you
wouldn't expect to find a solo cellist
and I'm just sitting down setting up
shop and starting to play and I'm
playing I'm doing six different
locations so it's an overture in about
cello suite in six different locations
for me it's incredibly exciting just to
sort of see that classical music is very
much alive and well and breathing and
that it's a part of our culture right
now and and that these living composers
are still thinking about music that was
written 300 years ago and bringing it
into the 21st century and and so I'm
very excited to be sort of doing
something of this scope right here at
Columbia
[Music]
[Applause]